very much and let's tie breaks starting
in a few minutes we're gonna definitely
follow that as well now Vincent with the
white pieces here we go busquin
situation for him here we go
okay the game has started it it's a
variation of the English opening or the
reti depending how you look at it
and it depends on magnus's next couple
of moves how will he set up
what do we think is he gonna go solid
Magnus or is he going to play
typically kind of Fighting Chess even
when he only needs a draw
uh well I think he's going to go solid I
mean he only needs to draw and it's
symmetrical English which is a very
solid opening isn't it generally and
well maybe now he's offering some tarash
transposition yeah um but uh Vincent's
gonna have to perform wonders to win
this game isn't he but he has got the
white pieces
what to do here David there's a couple
of choices right there's a few choices
white can push a couple of different
pawns forward in the center or you can
also just push the Jeep on forward
fiancato the bishop on the long diagonal
the white light Square Bishop
um those are the main three options okay
he pushes this Pawn will Magnus bring
his Knight out and just make the
position completely symmetrical that can
also push a pawn in the center
um yeah kg stuff so far it's so hard to
predict with Magnus that's the big
problem Vincent his opening repertoires
I mean it's just Flawless or my almost
but he is quite predictable uh in a way
at least relative to
the world number one but Magnus
immediately pushes forward in the center
and yeah we're going to see this really
tense standoff if black captures this
Pawn that's just moved we see a
transposition to the caricon defense uh
also potential transpositions to the
nimso Indian defense and this is why in
chess it's so hard I mean it started as
a an English opening kind of went into
the reti could be a caracon then could
end up as a nimzoo Indian so it's like
four different openings in one
um I've always found these positions
quite uh tricky to understand which Pawn
should you take first in the center with
black
you can wait you can maintain the
tension and not capture anything at all
it's a Magnus I think I've seen him on
the white side of this position as well
a few times a bunch of times even I'll
just check um he's I can certainly see
he's played it quite a few times he's
played against dingaran in March
and he played it against Anish giri in
2020
and he also beats uh artemia with the
black pieces in this let's have a look
so quite a lot of experience definitely
big names in there big opposition and
you're right uh he played Daniel dubov
and beat him in 2010 20 probably at
this it was the second tournament that
we commented on I think it's Masters yes
that was it yeah
a long time ago December 2020. we're
just trying to go back in time we've
been reminiscing about teenagers why not
reminisce about some great chess clashes
we've witnessed
meanwhile Magnus thinking I mean I'm
expecting him to capture one of the two
Pawns in the center but black could also
just bring his Knight out
um a move I think I've seen Magnus play
before as well is to just push the black
a pawn uh one square just as a bit of a
waiting move
that was against England
in the charity cup yeah maybe just
trying to okay he plays it again and
um yeah Magnus just maybe playing a game
of cat and mouse here he knows what he
wants to play but he's slightly afraid
that Vincent has prepared it we see a
Trader Pawns in the center
we see and there's potential for an
isolated Pawn again just like we saw two
games ago
one move I've played here is to push
this one I was about to say played this
myself
uh once before White's Bishop now has a
nice home and Black Blocks it up
yeah very ambitious play actually from
Magnus despite the fact he needs just
that draw
and now the pawn structure is in Balance
black has more space on the queen side
but white has an extra Central Pawn if
you look at the Central 2 files the E
and D files
what do you think of this one uh Simon
wait oh Ivanka yeah I was just gonna say
he's actually repeating the same formula
that he played against lettuce love
altemiev and the aim chess U.S rapid and
uh there he won in quite quick time
actually in 35 moves
yeah why mess with a winning recipe I
changed things up
and I'm expecting white to Castle here
White's Knight is pinned on this left
side of the board the other white knight
could also jump into the center though
as far as I remember there's a bunch of
moves White's dark squared Bishop can
protect
block this pin the Black Star Square
Bishop is creating
yeah any experiences here Simon this
type of position maybe no not really
um I mean I've sort of seen these
positions quite often again I just
assessing it you could Pawn structure
and pieces and
the thing I like about Black's Pawn
structure is that he probably has the
better Pawn structure in General on the
queen side especially because he's got
this chance of just getting a past Pawn
in any late middle game uh ending very
easily you can push all his Queen side
pawns up the board so that that's like a
long-term danger that Vincent has
Vincent flicking in a check here may be
entering into some slight tactics now
and Vincent I was going to say probably
has to use his pieces
to try and cause some problems and try
to use the center of the board and we're
seeing a little tactical exchange now so
there is some threats on magnus's
position yeah already I remember
analyzing this when I when I played it
back in 2019 I think it's white I didn't
go for this because I had seen that
okay from a human point of view looks
very tempting right you're undermining
this Knight it's pinned and uh also the
Black Knight defends its Bishop but I
think I remember think uh coming to the
conclusion that black can just castle
and now if we try to remove black snipe
from the board actually this uh
transition of a check a recapture and
taking back this is actually very
promising for black it looks great for
white two Bishops better Pawn structure
but for example here if white grabs a
pawn gets greedy then the black Bishop
just comes out and because this the
control of this diagonal is so strong
actually black has fantastic
compensation black will occupy the open
file white can never challenge for this
also this bishop tends to be quite bad
okay it's got one square right now but
it tends to be a bad piece and on the
light squares later on in the game white
only has one Defender maybe sometimes
later on you can exchange it off with
your Bishop and uh yeah I just remember
looking at plans like this one Simon
you'll be happy pushing the H1 forward
white has an extra Pawn but the quality
of the pieces is not great and Magnus
does eventually Castle yeah I mean so
maybe Vincent just well he's playing
very quickly here I mean maybe he must
have some idea
um but what you said there David makes a
lot of sense and um yeah Black's light
Square Bishop is a tremendous piece real
real strong piece there and I can tell
you that no one has ever played this
queen move in the database and it's
probably for the reasons that David
highlighted I still really like that
tweet by chafka this is the dog
fascinated by Magnus and his end game
skills this is the dog's teenage years
[Laughter]
sorry I have
a Fascination for pets especially dogs
yeah yeah so thank you chavka
definitely we do see a lot of cool pets
uh you guys sharing on social media
wonder if they enjoy watching chess or
if they're like what is this probably
they figured it out right because uh I
was reading in a book that like chimps
are actually much better at certain
tasks than us well quite actually set
and task quite a few tasks like in
memorization spotting patterns
chimps that's much better
where we all come from yeah maybe we
need an adjustable course by a pet yeah
meanwhile Black's Bishop coming out to
the stream diagonal and yeah even if you
lose a pawn as black black has those
doubled C pawns even if you lose the
back seat Pawn the White Queen can go
and take it right now
doesn't change anything really it's just
about the activity of the pieces also
black slight Square Bishop can come into
the position and just plant itself there
and it's pretty much there for eternity
and uh the first Blitz game has started
between Liam and origin and everybody
see Liam with the white pieces in this
one they have five minutes on the clock
three seconds after every move and after
this first Blitz game there will be
another one where Arjun will have the
white pieces you will definitely follow
this as well
behind us with a draw or win in this
game will be the winner in the rapid
portion and it looks good for him right
now it looks very good I mean if if
you're sacrificing a pawn which Magnus
is essentially doing and the computer
still loves your position it means
you've done something right you've got
uh full control
yeah I mean what do you guys uh foresee
in the next few moves it's been going to
be able to maybe change things up turn
things around just looks like that just
looks like Vincent's falling into a very
bad opening line actually uh which
you're aware of I mean it doesn't seem
that obvious to me uh that it's
completely disastrous and while he's
playing all the moves he recommended and
I I can see how things are going to
really
get hot around White's King but having a
plus two Advantage is is still like for
me it's like wow that is that is quite
intense right I'm surprised it's that
much actually yeah yeah but it's already
made attack and I really like that
obviously Rook up move that Magnus
played I mean you know we know where
that rook's gonna head to later on uh
over to the king side and discuss and
you know really Magnus has got these
like four pieces
um ready on the king side against
White's two pieces so just counting
attackers versus Defenders it it seems
like uh you know this is this is pretty
bad for white I mean white doesn't have
a plan right white it needs to find a
plan but what yeah what can he do he
can't redo anything so it's uh you know
he's it needs some luck here to to uh to
win this game uh it's just about this
open b-file if White's Rooks cook
adaptive great but unfortunately the
black Bishop keeps uh this Square
covered and yeah as you say in just zero
plan uh what's this queen doing
nothing at all at some point she'll
probably just have to return to her
start Square just to rejoin the action
on the king side uh what's this bishop
doing it's hitting thinner nothing to do
there's literally no Targets on the dark
squares and as you say ready-made plan
for example if White
I don't know moves the rook and the pawn
steps forward say I mean I don't even
see any moves really for white to say
the queen comes back the pawn could even
just step forward again uh maybe the
Black Knight is going to jump into the
center at some point hitting this Pawn
this is a big weakness the rook's gonna
swing the Queen's gonna come out
I mean you never ever want to trade this
piece off because then you lose all
control over the light squares around
White's King
looks disastrous almost and
um they're also even in positions like
this even if black didn't have anything
uh immediate you could just uh sorry you
could plant the bishop into this Outpost
any time you want and it will just
control some everything it's amazing how
bad White's position is because it
doesn't look like it should be as bad as
it is because you've got quite a solid
Pawn structure you're a pawn up you've
got two Bishops
um but actually the more you look at it
the more you realize it's it's
horrendous and there's nothing nothing
you can do here and okay he's trying to
stop your plan but you know moving pawns
around your King's very double-edged
because they can also be weak and become
targets at the same time and I guess the
downside is now if black ever plants are
not in the center of the board for
example hitting this Pawn now you can
never ever kick it away with your own
Pawn for example let's defend things
first
um not if it's not even easy to do but
um you can never ever kick your not the
night out because this Pawn is going to
be weak
again just looks like a ready-made
attack for black
at some point maybe not right now in the
current position okay Magnus jumps in
with his Bishop but at some point the
pawn will step forward there might even
be a sacrifice on this Square just to
open things up and you could imagine for
example The Rook swinging across and
this being very scary but Magnus he's
gonna pick his moment for that and okay
he jumps in with his Bishop
yeah I mean the the sacrifices around
White's King are always going to be
there I mean just thinking about most
embarrassing moments I mean um we've
talked about some but maybe not chess
related ones so much and I can probably
tell you my most embarrassing chess when
I I was an international Master playing
Hastings the tournament longest running
tournament in the world started in 1898
I think but the problem is is always
over the holiday period and they have a
game on New Year's Day can you believe
it so you've got to play a game on New
Year's Day and Hastings used to have
quite a famous pier where there was some
proper Raves going on all night um you
know finishing at eight eight a.m and I
remember just turning up for my New
Year's New Year's Day game
and I had the white pieces I was an
international master and I was playing
somewhere much much weaker than me and I
had to resign after eight moves
I hate moves and I I blended a piece on
move six when I was an international and
as soon as I blundered a piece sod's law
there was a massive crowd you know just
like oh look at this idiot I think I was
you know just couldn't even see and yeah
literally I resigned after eight moves
as an I am on New Year's Day and I think
my record on New Year's Day at Hastings
is like I think it's like one out of 11
or something it's terrible I've just
lost their lead so that was so
embarrassing losing like a baby to a
weaker player not fun not fun so yeah
anyone else done that lost probably not
that bad well I did have an embarrassing
chess loss but it wasn't it wasn't in
public and it was to see growing up I
had had a tremendous rivalry with my
older brother like he was much stronger
than me and he used to mock me
mercilessly mercilessly and anyway he
one day he turned around to me and said
can play you blindfolded in fact I'm
gonna beat you
I'm gonna I know that I'm gonna beat you
so I'm going to give you a queen odds so
he gave me Queen odds he played me
blindfolded
and he crushed me and because it's like
my brother he kind of stopped the
position he kind of immortalized it he
called the whole family round and he
said and then he took them through the
whole game and he got I'm sorry I'm
going red now just and he went like what
did she play he made every single member
of my family guess like all the moves
that I made and then big brother and
then when I when they suggested no no
that has some melodic he would say
oh yeah but you know it worked because
of him I I actually played thousands and
thousands of Blitz Games and I was very
motivated to become an international
Master yeah and uh yeah it made you
competitive yeah
a lot with families actually I mean
there's a famous pair of twins at the
position black is building up right
David and there's bound to be a big blow
soon but not much has actually occurred
at the moment but there's the you know
the poet Twins and because they were
twins they had this massive rivalry and
that's spurred them on both to become
well great players you know so you know
rivalry is quite healthy right yeah yeah
have you had that David Well yeah if
anyone particular I mean my siblings uh
siblings might hit one sister
um she didn't really play chess she
played one tournament lost all her games
but
um yeah I mean I had that rivalry I
guess I'm one of the 1990 crowds so when
I was already playing in these young age
groups the world under 10 Championship
World Under 12 Championship I was facing
and uh struggling against the likes of
Magnus
Etc but um I guess that gave me an edge
and also in England a few years above me
maybe but I had players like Dwayne
Jones there was a bit of a rivalry there
pushing each other to new heights as
soon as he achieved something I wanted
to do it too as soon as I achieved
something he wanted to do it and we kind
of pushed each other I think it's
healthy and that's it's no coincidence
now we see uh kind of okay we have the
1990 crew now it's like the 2006 2007
age group where all of these young
players or maybe even before that but
maybe all these players like Prague cash
sarin it's no coincidence they come
through at the same time because they
push each other to be better yeah and
Vincent's also in there at 17. Vincent
and um yeah I mean if you go up to 18 19
there's a bunch as well it's
yeah that's uh it's incredible rivalry
is healthy just remember it's not the
end goal just beating your rival you
want to get to the top of the world if
you don't want to just be your local
Champion
maybe you do but
meanwhile Magna is still building up
in this position all the black pieces
swarming towards the white king not
black oh this piece is perfect white is
helpless look at that white rook in the
bottom left corner can't get in the game
look at the other white Rook
poor white dark Square Bishop
it's uh
yeah it's just staring down at thinner
it's a disaster unfortunately in the
opening we'll Vincent yeah just to let
you know as well about the the playoffs
that going on um the first game Arjun
has the black pieces against Liam Lee
and it looks like Arjun is actually
winning uh with the black pieces there
which should be a really big step for
him getting getting into the final which
looks against Magnus Carson I very
excited about that final actually oh
yeah interesting
in those two fight which looks likely at
the moment but things can change yeah I
can see the bar
house off for our origin he has more
than two minutes on the clock Liam
onto a minute and 20 seconds
in that first Blitz game yeah you see a
rather desperate move there David played
but so this is the question does Magnus
use his bishop and go and take that
white Rook or does he leave it Black's
Bishop looks so good I would be tempted
to leave it
yes I mean this the materialistic
approach just grab that white Rook
for Bishop your material up and you have
a dominant position or
to maintain control do you just play for
having good pieces
yeah it's a Leo of material you know I
can't I can't resist I can't help it
it's too beautiful
I would be tempted to take it off just
because you know white gets control of
the b line if you if you don't take
so you can take this piece white will
recapture and
I mean there's so many tempting moves uh
you can maybe move the queen across for
example start eyeing up this Pawn
I mean your material up and you're just
doing well but um I guess it's also
I I don't know I know Magnus I've seen
enough games he's he wants to show a bit
of artistic Flair if he can and I think
he'll just Checkmate him yeah it's a
badge of honor that he doesn't want to
be materialistic or greedy I think like
you said Simon this bishop might
participate in the attack later so how
do we Checkmate this to stop the
demolishing stuff yeah just start
ripping the pawns away I'd say so I push
this one or take on G3 we're bang whip
him in yeah oh gosh she I didn't yeah I
didn't because this is a killer isn't it
you didn't even bring a rook in and yeah
I mean the rookie and hit the pawn hit
the queen I mean you could even start
with uh in this position pushing the
pawn forward maybe yeah to open up more
more diagonals yes I mean this is a pin
here white has to keep things closed if
you keep things closed The Rook comes in
here played us here definitely played us
he's just working out the variations
he's uh got lots of time it's quite an
obvious
kingside breaker isn't it
um
that's the thing I mean black in this
position is attacking with Bishop Rook
between another Rook White's pieces on
the other side especially these ones
they're just not oh what is that what he
goes back
Retreat that's not never why has he gone
that way why is he gone this way I guess
he wants to kind of he wants to
challenge The Rook maybe challenge The
Rook also he wants to maybe use this
diagonal to go for the white king I
guess I mean this will probably a good
move but when you can when you can uh
just kill your opponent's king you do it
right yeah is he enjoying himself too
much yeah he only needs a draw Magnus
after all but he's material up now as
well sometimes the best way to get draw
is just just to enter the complications
and in those other lines I mean even if
he didn't check mate there was bound to
be some Perpetual right so surprising
but still looks pretty good still looks
good yeah I'm not going to criticize it
because I might have gone for the same
thing myself bringing the queen all the
way back to it because you want to
challenge The Rook you know why it's the
only active piece is that Rook get rid
of it why don't you want to check mate
that's the aim it again it's not a
stylistic difference between YouTube
ends the game
where's the pleasure you know you're
killing you're a poder yeah yeah but no
but you're gonna have to play with the
food too exactly you're going for the
short kill you know the fast food I'm
gonna go for the long drawn Gourmet
you want the you want the full the full
yeah the full taste menu exactly
yeah Magnus looks pretty confident the
problem is for white it's just the
Bishops we love the two Bishops normally
but only when the center is open the
center is completely blocked
if you have a trade-off what your light
Square Bishop for Black's night again
the white king will get checkmated
eventually on those light squares the
other Bishop
just a bystander it's just two poor
pieces and White's Queen is pretty bad
too uh very very passive we have a win
for Arjun erag I see and Blitz game
number one with the black pieces in five
minutes but it's game number two with
the white pieces he will only need a
draw to be ready for the big final Liam
he has made a comeback before today so
he has to do the same in the next Blitz
game to take it to Armageddon
we will pay attention to that as well
but uh Magnus he is very likely now to
be the first player to enter the final
well I guess there's a lot of play left
in this one that's a lot of play but
it's it's all in one side's favor it's
just one-way traffic
white tried to plug the only open file
in the position is this B file white
tried to plug it with his DOT squared
Bishop but look at Magnus he's not going
for the attack sorry Simon he's just
switching his Focus if he can trade off
the Rooks trade off the Queens he has a
material advantage Rook for Bishop
and Black's night is super strong as
well
um yeah I I mean it's Such a Pity it had
to end like this assuming that Magnus
wins this game now because Vincent's
fought so well today it was just that
end game and then a poor opening choice
in this game I think again it's it's
hard to fall to him he needed to win
with white he took some risks he played
an opening maybe he's not so familiar
with
and uh Magnus needs a new the details
better
yeah
yeah it's easy it's easy to fall into a
bit of an inferior and opening against
someone like Magnus who plays everything
right you can get tricked I mean it's
very hard to know know what to do in all
positions before move 20 so
understandable and I think the last game
was really the the problem wasn't it not
you know Magnus grinding that ending all
the way through
um and but Kmart he came so close to
drawing didn't he so close yeah
um but he's going to be around for a
while I'm sure about that
yeah you know he's uh stopped school
he's focusing on the chess
years ahead at the top level yeah we've
got great coach great I mean
everything's in place for Vincent to
ascend to even higher
and I'm pretty sure he will
as judging on his performance this
tournament
but uh yeah I mean my prediction of a
Teenage player winning this event
if Vincent had taken down Magnus that
would have been guaranteed to Vincent
against uh Arjun perhaps well arjun's
you've got to go for him now really yeah
let's say arjun's the main man yeah and
maybe finding some inspiration and prag
his fellow Indian who actually won the
match against Magnus in Miami last month
he won them and Blitz tie breaks yeah
it's possible anything's possible I mean
to get to The Knockouts of these tour
events you have to be super super strong
so every guy see if he wins yeah he'll
deserve his shot at the crown Liam he's
been on Final before so we know he's got
pedigree as well meanwhile Vincent just
trying to block up the white king if you
look at the white porn structure all on
dark squares ignoring that white apron
the rest all on dark squares that shows
he's only weak on one color complex and
Magnus happy to give up a pawn to bring
his rook in
okay he's not allowed to do that what uh
White is now stopping the Black Rock
from coming to the second rank
but this is just a temporary leisure
I mean white can barely move
right now
still got to find a breakthrough I mean
uh just gotta avoid over pressing and
find a way to breach White's defenses
so how do we do that yeah it's not so
easy actually not so we don't have to do
anything because the onus is on white to
try to prove so you could just kind of
solidify your Pawn structure there on
the right say we defend it yeah you know
I'm not bothering to go for mate I
understand there's much more ambitious
tries and then how is white ever going
to make any progress
if you kick back the night then you
create weaknesses
yep and now these pawns are very weak
I guess if you ever step forward with
your queen the black Rook wall
infiltrate and invade the white Camp
we'd see okay the black queen come in
this would be deadly as well white is a
bit Frozen but uh okay Magnus
that was up his Rooks not sure where
that one's going
is it going this way maybe does he want
to Checkmate after all Simon
say I mean he could also do the
alacrine's gun on on the B file which
we've talked about
um quite a lot actually this tournament
where you can triple up your pieces like
that and then you just bring your rook
in swap off more pieces and uh win in
this way maybe another idea I mean this
is perfect uh kind of placement for
pieces takes a few moves but yeah maybe
he has that luxury
clock times as well they've just been
against Vincent the whole match
yeah yeah he's always fighting an uphill
battle on the board and the clock
unfortunately so right now
hard to find
well hard to recommend anything for
white unfortunately what's game number
two just started between Nairobi and
Liam Lee with the white pieces Arjun
will need only a draw or a win to be
ready for his very first final in the
mouthwater Champions chess tour
to also make it to his first no he's
been in one he's been in one before did
he
he's been in one final before yeah he's
been and I remember he lost it yeah
I think probably you're right against
love one if he was either Levon or
Artemis where's our stats guys
yep
he's been in a final but right now it
looks like Arjun will make it to his
first final
but in his Blitz game he is playing a
former blitzworld Champion so anything
can happen we are paying attention to
that as well you think this game will be
finished before lab Blitz game or is
there a lot left to do in this one this
there's enough to do to make it last
quite a while Magnus has a lot of time
on the clock as well I guess so he could
spend that a bit later on
um yeah I mean it would be fun to watch
that Blitz game that second Blitz game
between the two yeah let's see whether
Magnus can finish Vincent off first
Vince's clock time
it does really say that uh he's not
going to survive too long unfortunately
but um okay he just moves his Rook
awaiting move
no real aggressive intentions behind
that one it feels like
and maybe time for that alacrine's gun
as you mentioned stacking up all those
three black pieces
yeah I think the white king is safe
enough for now not too many attackers
around it so
it wouldn't make sense too much for
Magnus to gamble and go for the white
king
okay I was trying to get in from a
different angle of that Queen this also
looks uh quite effective as well his
position is so winning I think he could
do anything and as long as he has
the kickback of the Black Knight under
control and he does there's no problem
yeah so the black queen now is going to
find her way on that Queen side she's
going to go diagonally over to A4 and
actually that white dark sky Bishop is
the target yeah yeah logical stuff the
queen will sneak in maybe even win
another Pawn right so yeah yeah I mean
it's nice full board awareness as well
just kind of it looks like the Queen's
been staring down at the white king the
whole time and
going all the way back there
um also one minute on the clock so it's
uh maybe this game will finish before
the second Blitz game and the other
semi-final is over yeah and uh Now The
Rook comes and uh well there's really
nothing much for Vincent to do except
kick back the Black Knights and whilst
Magnus is pondering Where to return the
night
um we have a funny tweet from LOL Keck
who says that they want us to do
commentary on the on his day-to-day or
her day-to-day oh no he goes for Netflix
instead of the gym Elementary blunder
minus nine for him with no hope of
recovering from this position yeah he's
off to the bar
rest is important too though yeah
okay providing the balance
and uh yeah thank you LOL for that tweet
he hasn't made a move for eight hours
what's he doing
Tick Tock the clock is ticking
stick reminds me of that
that Jim Carrey movie where he's his
life is uh The Truman Show yeah yeah
it's good and Simon would be that
peculiar yeah
What A peculiar day-to-day routine it
would actually be a little bit of a fun
experiment for like for 24 hours you're
gonna have sports commentators
comment on your life yeah I think that
should be another Well a new chess
documentary just where they follow chess
players around yeah more happens than
meets the eye it's not always just
staring at a computer screen studying
openings behind the scenes behind the
scenes yeah
interesting yeah meanwhile camera down
to under 20 seconds now
the problem is it's all falling apart
white has had to weaken his Pawn
structure in order to kick back Black's
night and
Magnus doesn't even want that trade of
Rooks which would still be favorable for
him instead he's going to control the
second rank that's a nice uh a nice move
okay Vincent's really trying to force
that trade
but just compare the pieces Black's Rook
is more active than White Strip so no
Exchange
it's uh sometimes that simple
and uh I I mean
he's fighting credits of Vincent and an
update on uh Liam's game he needs to win
with the black pieces and uh he's a
piece up so it's quite likely we might
get an Armageddon uh encounter between
Arjun and it's very complicated still
but he's done exactly the right thing in
complicating and getting a very weird
position okay it's actually very unclear
but
here's a piece up when I see Armageddon
chest today we're Mighty yeah it might
see our first Armageddon which should be
uh great yeah yeah so we've only had one
I think one Armageddon on the tour on
the tour and that was between uh Gary
and
someone just last month
our memory is you know it's been a long
day uh so Thai uh reminded me it was uh
chessable Masters Liam Lee lost to
Wesley Seoul actually I was gonna say
Wesley I was yeah that was wrong there
we go it's uh yeah meanwhile okay
Vincent step forward in the center but
this pseudo sacrifice just giving back
some material for uh for black who's
looks like a killer if white takes this
Rook he loses his light Square Bishop
The Black Queen will come in the white
king is doomed just that second rank
black has got full control
okay he doesn't even capture but now the
two books are gonna line up so maybe a
small threat White's Rook wants to come
to the top of the board and pin the
black queen to her king that's probably
still losing yeah yeah it doesn't look
like a massive threat yeah I'm not the
scariest that can avoid that if he
wishes I reckon here try to
he'll try to give up his Queen here
won't he Magnus if he can you know
probably can give up his Queen to at
least get a Perpetual go for that white
king yeah
but he doesn't like going for chipmate
there you go he's going to check mate
yeah
I think he'll achieve it
yeah looks very good so white is about
to win the black queen but he's had to
give up a bishop so right now
okay two Rooks for a queen but at the
very least the White Queen is going to
drop off yeah there we go the White
Queen is doomed and Magnus Carson is in
the final all right it's another final
for the world number one knocking out
young Vincent kymer in uh the
semi-finals